wenn ihr das video hier gerade sie das
sonst der erste sechste das leben freude
in einigen
gleichwohl konnten
online
unter anderem diese art sexy
er hat sogar eine kapuze also wenn ihre
herzlichkeit und ihr einfach so machen
sie die aber ich werde mich auf jeden
fall sehr freuen wenn die gleich um 15
uhr einfach mal luca - shop.de
vorbeischauen würde dann gehen dort
nämlich die fünf neuen produkte der
neuen kollektion matter online von jedem
produkt von dem gewinn spenden wir ein
euro an die stiftung gegen rassismus nur
die ersten 1000 besteller bekommen von
mir einen bunten handsignierten lukas
ticker ihrer bestellung beigefügt also
schaue auf jeden fall dort vorbei und
jetzt starte mit dem video ok ich hab
keinen plan was das ist ich glaube ein
presslufthammer dass sie ist im stift
der offenen tisch gehalten wird und
irgend eine spiegelung verursacht das
hier ist kleber glaube ich und er packt
diesen kleber mit seinen fingern
übernimmt damit machen übrigens nicht
nur aussagen channel ich war gar nicht
erwähnt also wir schauen uns ein video
an und ich darf nicht sowas sagen wie
wow oder what oder krass oder was oder
irgendwie also ich darf nicht meine
verwunderung zum ausdruck bringen dass
hier ist das nächste video ist es eine
[Musik]
seht ihr
das ist
ich sag nix hier geht es weiter mit
einer straße bzw
da die sieht aus als wäre als
hier ist jemand in der wüste und hat
eine flasche mit sandra nicht auf das
hat jeder schon mal nein wirklich dumm
ich habe soeben mein erstes leben
verloren und habe dementsprechend nur
noch vier das sieht ja mal mega krass
aus das ist einfach so ein loch mitten
im wasser award okay das ist krass
das gilt übrigens nicht weil gleiche
clip war das hier ist ein
ich habe keine ahnung was das war und
das dann einfach zwei züge die andocken
keine ahnung was das hier ist aber ich
glaube der holt da honig raus wenn ich
nicht komplett dumm bin
das hier ist irgendwie so ein zeichen
aus irgendeiner serie dass es aus juba
vielleicht sogar das zeichne ich habe
keine ahnung
das hier ist das
das ist nach
steckdose also bisher musste ich
wirklich nur bei diesem also das war
auch schon krass dieses loch vier leben
habe ich auf jeden fall noch das hier
ist ein zug oder irgendwie sowas ein
spielzeug und das eda
das war ne das war eine wasserflasche
cooles wasserflaschen die seite muss man
sagen keine ahnung was hier wieder
abgeht
ich glaube der zieht achte er macht
direkt von einem holzstück weg oder was
macht er da genau ich weiß nicht genau
oder ein lackiertes wie ich habe keine
ahnung genau was er das veranstaltet hat
die h ja ich habe schon wieder aber auch
gesagt gebt euch das wahlalter city mega
krass aus das ding ist es sieht ein
bisschen so aus als wäre die kugel im
nachhinein da irgendwie rein gefordert
worden aber wir müssen erstmal sagen
hier ein leben habe ich wieder verloren
das heißt noch drei das hier ist lassen
ist
hat
sid bisschen verstören aus allerdings
habe ich nicht gesagt oder krass oder
irgendwie sowas in die richtung ich hab
nur gesagt das heißt ich habe weiterhin
meiner drei leben ich habe keine ahnung
was das hier ist ich glaube achte
erhitzt einfach so metall und dann zieht
sich das zusammen oder wie genau
eigentlich das ja ich habe mich
physikalisch mal wieder komplett zum
affen gemacht hast jetzt eine
sprinkleranlage die gesteuert wird über
einen schalter
ok also achtet mal wenn die an geht
jetzt hier
das hier ist das nächste video ich
glaube das sind uhren wenn ich mich
nicht ganz
oder sind das sind das fitnessgerät ich
glaube es ist
steht er
basketball platz unter wasser ja also
das wäre auf jeden fall ein video wo ich
war aussagen würden werde überfluteter
basketballplatz aber gut wir machen wir
weiter hier mit dem nächsten video
es ist ein kleines fahrzeug ein mega
mega schnelles kleines auf ca
das hier ist das nächste video uns war
es das wasser aber es ist
sieht aus wie milch alter glaube einfach
weil das wasser so nicht gereinigt ist
oder so 802 leben habe ich nur noch ich
dachte er ist der typ wollte uns zeigen
die milch ist das wasser aussieht aber
es verändert die farbe das sieht dann
vielleicht im keine ahnung woran das
genau liegt ich habe überhaupt kein plan
ehrlich gesagt dass jetzt eine
nudelmaschine dieser nudeln aufdreht ich
habe auch kein plan
wofür die gut ist dass hier sind kekse
oder irgendwie sowas glaube ich wieder
verteilt werden beziehungsweise die auch
so ein laufband gelegt werden und hier
sehen wir nun einen weg beziehungsweise
nie das ist eine lichtshow oder
irgendwie sowas oder ist es ich weiß
nicht ob das von unten gefilmt ist und
dann nach oben hin ich glaub schon oder
von oben nach unten oder ist also keine
ahnung was ist dass ich glaube dass es
in einer in einer euro
ja
alter das ist live act 10.000 das hier
ist ein handy und das ist eine folie die
da drauf gelegt wird und nur dadurch
kann man den bildschirm dann sehen okay
das ist auch krass das hier ist glaube
ich ein café oder keine ahnung was das
ist ist das sehr ich glaube dass es das
ist ein joghurt ich keine ahnung genau
da liegt auf jeden fall irgendwie was
drauf irgendwie glasierte schokolade da
so was die essen paar snacks und auch
keine ahnung was das hier jetzt wieder
darstellen soll der kommt einfach ganz
viele kleine murmeln heruntergerollt aus
irgend so ein fabrikat dingsbums sie
spinnt wolle einfach oder ich glaube
schon
ich glaube ja dass hier schon wieder
irgendwie sowas und das ist das ist
glaube ich dann wirklich gegen den tc
aber ich weiß nicht ob das eine zwiebel
dar ein punkt hier ist jemand mit seinem
mähdrescher und packt da das ganze gibt
rein oder was auch immer das ist da raus
und das alles in seinen in seiner
carolina
sie reinigt ein ich habe keine ahnung
ist übrigens seit dass die clips auch
keinen ton haben aber werden halt als
compilations hochgeladen und dann ist
dir der hintergrund sound halt einfach
sondern es hat das folgen musik aber gut
wie mama weiterhin mit dem nächsten
video m das sind welle die kann man
klein treten an das ist wenn man die
transportieren will und dann sind die
nachher blasen sie selbst wieder auf ich
glaube das wird ja auch mal bei einem
fußball wird auch mal
ein wort ein selbst auflösen auf habe
ich gerade
hier schneidet jemand haargenau ein
stoff zu recht beziehungsweise leder
oder so und die jungs hier die haben
glaube ich einen drachen und hängen
denen ihr das ist doch was ist denn das
weiter geht es hier wieder irgendwo auf
einer plantage oder irgend sowas ich
doch das sind alles früchte die da
zusammen gepackt haben hier straight
einer irgendwas auf dem boden
jetzt nehmen sie das ding hoch und ja es
ist zeit eine schablone man muss
wirklich sagen dass 80 prozent der clips
die hier in der compilation diesmal drin
sind das die wirklich nicht clips sind
wo man jetzt nicht denken würde ok krass
auch dass wir da was ist denn das
fach
projiziert an soll das hier ist ein
fußballstadion das gerade noch im bau
ist ich glaube das könnte sogar
südafrika sein was die zur wm gemacht
haben
das hier ist ja absolut kein laden
was das ok ich habe nicht gesagt aber
sieht wunder wunderschön aus das ist in
captain america feuerzeug oder sowas
nächsten stift ok krass ist auf jeden
fall auch dann kann er damit schreiben
ja so glückwunsch das hier ist
jemand minigolf und das war's wir
schütten leute wasser aus und aber was
war das denn ich dachte erst die
schützen irgendwie was zu hause und
wollen was menschen aber dann kommt auf
einmal diese teile raus das sind das
kühl stäbe deswegen ein spiel oder so
relativ ist aber ich habe es doch
relativ weit geschafft dem video
also es geht jetzt nur noch eine halbe
minute können wir es
generiert er dadurch dass er im kreis
fährt dort einen strudel oder ja an
deshalb möchte ich wieder zeit ist aber
entweder lieben freunde werden euch
meine trainer challandes heute gefallen
hat das gerne einen daumen hoch unter
dem video abonniert main kanal falls
noch kein trainer luka seid und wie
bereits zu beginn des videos gesagt
gleich um 15 uhr lounge neue klamotten
luca - shop.de von dem gewinn jedes
produkte spenden wir ein euro an die
stiftung gegen rassismus da der
kollektions gedanke jupiter einfach
bedeutet jede person ist gleich jeder
mensch ist gleich und deswegen haben wir
uns auch beispielsweise solche designs
überlegt verschiedene farben miteinander
kombinieren ich würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr einfach mal im shop
vorbeischauen würde ich werde auch
einige von euch besuchen und eventuell
dir persönlich dann dein merchandise
übergeben
[Musik]